-Our next guest
has his stand-up special
"Practicing?" available
now on YouTube.
Please welcome the very funny
Jesus Trejo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Thank you. Thank you.
Please have a seat.
Have a seat, you guys.
Thank you so much.
I tipped my Uber driver 50 bucks
cash. Yeah.
You don't do something like that
and not tell anyone, so...
[ Laughter ]
So I'll tell you guys.
I tipped him 50 bucks
because I wanted him to pretend
we were a family
when he dropped me off
at the airport.
He was good, man.
He got out. We hugged.
He stood there and waved
at me aggressively.
And as I'm walking away, I'm
pretending to be embarrassed.
I'm like, "Alright, man, chill."
[ Laughter ]
Ten minutes later,
he sends me a text.
"Are you at the gate yet?"
[ Laughter ]
I mean, this transaction's over,
bro.
[ Laughter ]
I'm excited.
I'm back in the gym.
I started going back.
I made the mistake of asking
for a personal trainer.
Don't do that.
The buffest guy came out.
He goes, "It's 150."
I'm like, "Stop right there.
I don't care if it's a day,
month or year.
Not interested."
They need a cheaper option.
Like, give me a chubby
personal trainer.
[ Laughter ]
Someone who I can build
with together.
How much is it?
Accountability, bro.
Let's do this.
[ Laughter and applause ]
What does a personal trainer do?
Count?
You're there bench-pressing.
"One!"
That's what I said, man.
[ Laughter ]
My biggest pet peeve
is when they spot
you using their index finger.
I hate that. They're like,
"There you go, there you go.
All you, all you.
There you go, there."
Then why are you here?
I paid for the whole hand.
Use the whole hand.
[ Laughter ]
I feel like if you have
a chubby personal trainer,
any question they ask you,
you can answer by
asking it right back.
"Are you going to be
here tomorrow?"
Bro, are you going to
be here tomorrow?
"Are you eating what
you're supposed to?"
Bro, are you eating
what you're supposed to?
Yeah, there's a guy
that goes to my gym
and he shadow boxes,
like for hours.
He goes there.
I want to go up to him like,
"Bro,
you have that machine at home."
[ Laughter ]
"Go home.
Take the push-up guy with you."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you.
I feel like you have to be super
optimistic to be a shadow boxer.
Have you ever seen
a shadow boxer lose?
[ Laughter ]
They always win.
Like, if I did it, I would lose.
Ooh, ooh, ooh.
"Are you okay?"
Man, you should have seen
my shadow, bro.
[ Laughter ]
It's a big shadow, man.
I've never been --
I've never been
to an escape room,
but I feel like
I would suck at them.
It took me 35 years to move out
of my parents' apartment.
[ Laughter ]
So what am I going
to do with one hour?
That's stressful.
There's a lot that goes
into escaping a room.
Finances,
your mother's blessing.
[ Laughter ]
I was going to go to one,
and I went to the website first
and the website said,
"If you can't figure it out,
don't worry,
we let you right out."
I'm like, that's B.S.
If I pay $30 and I don't
solve it, leave me here.
Bring the next group in.
Come on, have a seat, you guys.
They'll walk in.
"Do you work here?"
No. I couldn't solve the puzzle.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you.
"I couldn't solve the puzzle.
Yeah. I haven't been
to work in a week.
Can you help me?"
The concept of escape rooms
to me is very funny.
Like, your life
is that good that you have
extra time and money
for more problems?
[ Laughter ]
It's like, I'm going to turn my
apartment into an escape room.
It's like I got to figure out
how to get dad health insurance.
Time starts now. Go for it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, man, you guys are the best.
[ Applause continues ]
I just got a jury summons.
Yeah, they're sending
them out right now.
So when you go home,
don't check your mailbox.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, I just got a jury
summons in the mail.
And you know
what's interesting?
That the jury summons landed
on the same day I have court.
So we'll see.
[ Laughter ]
Fingers crossed I get to be
a juror on my case.
[ Laughter ]
I'll be there for sure. Like,
"Your Honor, I know that guy.
He's a good guy, that guy.
He wouldn't even fight
his own shadow."
My name's Jesus Trejo.
That's my time.
Thank you guys so much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you, buddy.
Jesus Trejo!
"Practicing?" is available
now on YouTube.
We'll be right back, everybody.